[Musique]
sur la foi de cet article j'avais
l'intention de vous emmener à pigalle
non pas comme vous pourriez le penser
ingénument pour y faire la tournée des
cabarets mais pour vous faire connaître
un personnage unique en son genre le
seul dessinateur intradermique de france
autrement dit un tatoueur disons légal
mettant le tatouage à la portée de tous
malheureusement il a disparu pour un
temps de pigalle et c'est dans un
endroit beaucoup moins agréable que vous
pourrez vous initier à ces secrets et y
apprendre que si le tatouage clandestins
à ses bottés
il y a une différence importante entre
monsieur bruno est le tatouage le mât
fond voici à nanterre le camion
laboratoire avec lequel monsieur bruno a
visité tous les ports de france et même
de l'étranger
voici monsieur bruno
je vous laisse avec ces aiguilles
qu'est ce que vous faites exactement là
à motifs de tatouage
je fais ça sur un papier waterproof si
l'on peut dire c'est à dire il ne se
décomposent pas et il imprègne le têt le
dessin le motif plus exactement à
l'endroit précis où je dois voir que je
voudrais le faire parce que vous êtes
votre propre dessinateur pour certains
modèles wi l'inventer certains mais il y
en a de très très commun que l'on
rencontre dans tous les dictionnaires
les motifs traditionnels alors au gré
auprès du client ou regret personnel du
du tatoueur on les mots dits fillon et
raffinent ou enfin sais pas combien de
temps pour faire la tête tout est
variable mais c'est ce que ça fait mal
c'est ça être non du fait que maintenant
avec les machines modernes qui tourne
dans ta électrique électricité
on arrive à tourner à la vitesse aux
abords de 5000 tours minute voyez vous
j'ai vu des tatoueurs qui était vraiment
les statiques
en ce sens il était le bestial brutale
c'est être mais moi je m'efforce
d'alléger un petit peu cette chose à
éviter d'amener entre le tatoué et moi
un terrain d'entente un climat disons
préfecture n'ont pas très amical wayuu
ses tatouages ou montre la différence
entre le travail officiel il clandestins
et ce n'est pas dans un fort mal famés
mais roland qu'à la suite d'un accident
de voiture dont il était témoin monsieur
bruno découvrit le tatouage c'est m et
c'est m en effet pour bénéficier d'un
délai de transfusion en nombre de
hollandais se sont fait tatouer leur
groupe sanguin le plus grand toit je
devrais dire ceux de volt est à mon avis
le canada et en europe
le canada oui et en europe la norvège
les norvégiens sont très très très peu
joué il ya trois sortes de tatouage il
opta toise artistique médical ta touche
esthétique
quels sont ceux qu'on fait avec laquelle
non j'attends foule en français vinci et
bien c'est se situe d'abord pour des
garçons de 20
25 en même temps d'envoyer bon et alors
c'est beaucoup beaucoup
le reptile à qu'est ce que c'est vrai
que symbolique quand ça vous dit quoi
symboliquement ça veut dire ou venger ou
vengeance alors tout dépend de
l'orientation qu'elle a peut-être qui si
elle est en haut c'est vengeance ci est
angoissé venger
voilà des reptiles ici par exemple ici
voyez-vous la tête en bas oui s'il a été
vengé c'est ça ici la tête en haut
oui alors il ya ici une tête en l'air
mairie donc rangeant ce chagrin d'amour
et vengeance chez rien à vos rivaux
jours donc il se venge de la fal qui
opposait sont souvent l'amour c'est ça
alors d'autres sont des combats de
reptiles et automatiquement il espère
vengeance tant que l'animal est nominé
parvenir à 20 filiales dans le tatouage
artistique tatouage mobile qui est le
grand aigle avait sur la poitrine et
lorsque l'individu remue les épaules
voyez vous remue les bras les allées
lors revu
il y avait des tas de motifs de tant de
petites mobilise le chat sur le bras
lorsque l'on contre le voileux
s'affaireront à l'origine voyez-vous le
tatouage et elles en font quelque chose
de religieux une idole un totem et est
tatoué sur la peau de quelqu'un ça
représentait quelque chose pour ce
quelqu'un comme ça représente toujours
quelque chose
et à l'heure actuelle je pense que les
personnes qui se fait tatouer son sirh
et bien c'est une affection particulière
un de ceux ci mais vous l adle domaine
affectif comme ce théâtre il l'amour de
son existence
là on attaque les tatouages sentimentaux
parce que c'est ça existe aussi et alors
par exemple voyez vous on tombe dans la
série des coeurs alors ça je sais c'est
l'amour sentimentale en général j'ai
maintenant nous arrivons dans une autre
série voyez-vous l'amour
enfin le sentiment est là il est marqué
par exemple à la suite d'un portrait
d'une photo et on m'apporte une photo et
je m'efforce en 5 ou 10 croquis de
retrouver l'aspect de la personne que
l'on désire avoir tatoué et à ce moment
là c'est vraiment le tatouage
sentimentale entier qui se rattachent à
quelqu'un ici vous êtes sec les hommes
sont plus fidèles s'ils ont la femme
d'être ici rue
c'est en tous les cas une très grande
preuve d'amour
ça c'est le cas d'un monsieur qui un
jour m'a demandé de lui faire le visage
de son enfant
or comme il fallait lagré montée d'un de
quelque chose décoratifs et bien j'ai
pensé que la rose était tout indiqué
c'est à dire que le dessin peut pas lui
même est représentatif et alors la rose
l'emblème de l'amour avec la tête de son
bébé
j'ai des tatouages préférées voilà par
exemple ici une vahiné à wailly et
singapour moyer vous ce sont des motifs
rechercher sans trop de couleurs de sons
des motifs tendre purement décoratif
j'ai fait beaucoup comme ça j'en ai déjà
fait deux en france et les gens sont
heureux d'avoir une belle hawaïenne
comme ça sur le heureux pour le restant
de leur vie
j'ai dès l'instant où un monsieur se
fait faire un motif c'est qu'ils le
désirent à moins d'être inconscient
oui mais dès l'instant où il a quelque
chose de très joli quelque chose qu'il
verra chaque jour en se lavant et bien
il vaut mieux voir quelque chose de joli
quelque chose de laid est aussi le
tatouage esthétique c'est réparé une
malformation naturel de loyer vous et
c'est là où on a on intervient alors
sans enfant honte à tous sans encre
alors il ya différentes applications
application il y avait tout ce qui était
jusqu'ici la chose comme ça c'est un oui
mais à la haye est ce que vous arrivez
par exemple vraiment à faire disparaître
oui enfin dans la tête dans la
généralité oui oui vous mais il ya des
corps rebelles temps tout comme dans
tout enfin en principe on arrive assez
bien oui alors là ça rejoint le tatouage
médical tatouage médicales esthétiques
si l'on veut plutôt oui l'on fonce et
esthétique à rotterdam
un collègue haro tatouer une rétine
deuil ce monsieur avait perdu la vue
sont devenus blancs et on a retrouvé la
rétine si bien que le regard est resté
vif et on a évité l'oeil de verre voyez
vous c'est une des applications majeures
majeur de ce fameux tatouage médical ou
esthétique avec ce que vous dites là
c'est presque un maquillage antilles qui
ne partira jamais c'est courant dans les
flammes
ces courants en suède voyez vous les
femmes se font tatouer des lèvres rouges
se font enfin certaines ont eu lieu
cette fois ci se font tatouer les
et si les paupières c'est simple je n'ai
pas de préjugés et bien souvent je
m'efforce d'orienter la personne qui
désire quelque chose vers quelque chose
de plus esthétique depuis jolie
voyez-vous weeds essayer d'affiner son
bonjour qu'est celui en recrutant le des
fois quelque chose de brutal comme qui
dirait un poignard brunel quoi eh bien
je la mènerai en faire un très joli
arrondies qui tout en gardant le motif
propre aura un aspect et un coup d'oeil
bien plus je le dis c'est mon rôle
il ya énormément de gens en france qui
part font leur culture personnelle
voyous et j'aime beaucoup ces gens là
parce qu'ils ignorent totalement le
tatouage pour eux c'était quelque chose
de très mal prise et et du fait que l'on
amène quelque chose de nouveau et bien
des gens aiment à parfaire leur culture
elles viennent d'inventer avec vous il
veut me garder avec moi et nous parlons
en ami et ga je suis arrivé pardon à en
convaincre un qui était absolument en
titre 3 à 100% et je lui ai fait son
groupe sanguin
oui c'est ce qu'ils étaient et le
lendemain il m'a mené sa femme et son
fils
voyez-vous ce sont des choses à
développer à l'origine les gens ignorent
mais si on développe le sujet
amicalement loyalement on arrive alors
faire admettre qu'il ya de l'utile
vous pensez vraiment vous allez pouvoir
gagner votre vie à pigalle en faisant
des tatouages vision honnête vous
entendez par là tatouage sa vaquin
distincts a et n'y aucune raison que je
serai clandestins du fait que j'ai fait
tout ce qu'il y avait en france et que
j'ai suivi la législation en plein et je
pense travailler à pigalle du fait que
lorsque l'on part dans un métier nov aps
quelque part on mise sur le fameux kit
une houle mai
dès maintenant je sais qu'en france ça
marchera et puis pourquoi pas puisque
dans tous les pays du monde que ce soit
et les pays du groupe latin aux
nordiques ou enfin peu importe il y à
des cancers partout il y à des amours
partout il y a des des durs partout et
oui il ya des voleurs et enfin
[Musique]
encore un mot pour vous apprendre que
monsieur bruno a abandonné son camion
pour avoir pignon sur rue sauf à pigalle
tiens tiens
[Musique]